this video contains spoilers for John
Wick chapter 4. at the end of his latest
movie we see the death of John Wick but
is everyone's favorite puppy-loving
assassin really dead what say you John
you're dead right Emily no he's alive
and I'm about to prove it Long Live John
Wick
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that knows that no business can
be done on Continental grounds so why
not subscribe and watch some of our
videos instead oh boy loyal theorists
today we're talking about one of my
favorite franchises to pop up over the
past decade John Wick you ready John in
case you missed this one John Wick is
about a legendary assassin seeking
revenge against the entire criminal
underworld known collectively as the
high table after they kill his dog later
movies are less about the dog and more
about just leaving the organization but
regardless these films have a pretty
simple premise what follows then are
four films of incredible action in a
super stylish neon lit world all
directed by stunt professionals who make
sure you see exactly what's going on and
I think the results speak for themselves
John Wick is one of those rare
franchises where each sequel is arguably
better than the entry that came before
with box office numbers to match not
that much of a shock when it's clear how
much love is put into these things but
you know what was a shock John Wick's
death at the end of chapter four after
months of running and fighting his way
through endless armies of faceless goons
Jon is forced into one final duel
against his old friend Kane in it he
shot three times and although he manages
to survive long enough to kill the big
boss and win his freedom minutes later
he takes a seat and peacefully succumbs
to his wounds to say that literally no
one saw this coming is putting things
mildly as I was walking out of my
showing in the movie I heard multiple
people asking each other he can't be
dead right I mean it takes a lot to
surprise me in movies at this point and
even I gotta admit this one got me John
Wick is a huge franchise there is a
hunger from fans for more of these
movies and now at the height of their
success they kill off the main character
no I don't think so it doesn't matter if
we saw a grave because John Wick isn't
dead when you actually look at this
franchise and examine the type of
injuries that Wick sustained throughout
his quest to escape the high table
things do not line up here there is no
way that the wounds that he takes on
this Final Duel kill him in fact not
only is John Wick not dead but after
watching these movies again I am almost
100 convinced that John Wick literally
cannot die and there's a secret reason
for it so put on your magic bulletproof
suit loyal theorists we've got a death
to disprove so to do this analysis we're
gonna be lumping the movies into two
groups John Wick chapters one through
three and John Wick chapter four why
well it has to do with the time frame
where the movies take place according to
franchise director Chad stilleski the
first three John Wick movies take place
in like a week week and a half somewhere
in there so all this fighting all the
goons he kills all the damage that he
takes across those three movies yep all
of that's apparently happening in just
under two weeks meanwhile here I am
weeping on the floor every time I step
on a Lego on the other hand chapter 4
apparently takes place like six months
later enough time that John will have
had himself a chance to rest heal and
refill his tank additionally we're only
gonna be looking at the major injuries
here sure he sustains plenty of punches
and falls through glass but we're gonna
be focusing on the moments that stand
the best chances of kill killing him and
it seems to me that the best starting
point is actually the End by taking a
closer look at the wounds that do wind
up quote unquote killing him during this
final shootout Kane grazes Wick's right
arm hits his left shoulder and then
shoots his lower abdomen the resulting
blood loss then seemingly causes Wick to
die shortly thereafter but hold on for a
second there why does that wound pattern
sound so familiar well because this
isn't the first time that we've seen
someone shot in these places in the
franchise in chapter 3 John is forced to
shoot a friendly doctor in order to save
his life it's complicated but trust me
it works anyway week asks where the
doctor would like to be shot and the
doctor points to two specific locations
that'll hurt so it won't be fatal where
here just below my floating rib oh wait
one may not be enough you should not to
graze Mike good luck Mr Rick the first
is in his lower abdomen side and the
second is through his shoulder the exact
same parts of the body where Kane hits
Wick during their shootout at the end of
chapter four and remember the doctor
chose those spots specifically because
they wouldn't be outright fatal that
right there that is highly suspicious
not only that but Jon also shot Kane in
the same part of the abdomen and we see
him able to make a full recovery by
chapter 4's post-credits scene so
already we have ourselves two solid
points of evidence indicating that Jon
shouldn't be dead at the end of this
duel and all of that is without saying
that these guys are trained
professionals they can get a head shot
in their sleep the fact that they're
only grazing each other and hitting
non-essential areas that right there is
a dead giveaway that something else is
afoot but let's just talk for a second
about blood loss according to the
National Library of Medicine healthy
adults have an average of four and a
half to five and a half liters of blood
circulating through their bodies at any
given time obviously everyone's gonna
react to trauma differently but as a
general guideline most adults can lose
up to 15 percent of that blood volume
without any sort of physical symptom
this is known as a Class 1 Hemorrhage
anything above that though symptoms get
progressively worse between 15 and 40
blood loss can result in nausea fatigue
and hallucination it isn't until you get
to 40 or more blood loss where things
start to become seriously deadly these
are the class IV hemorrhages they're the
sorts of wounds that have high risks of
organ failure coma and death so how much
blood does John lose well to calculate
that we need to know how badly he was
injured according to the Internet movie
Firearms database the guns used in the
duel appear to be a pair of engraved
Thompson Center Arms Encore pistols with
nickel plated or silver cast 44 magnum
cartridges how powerful is a 44 magnum
cartridge in the words of Dirty Harry
powerful handgun
blow your head clean off these should be
doing some significant damage emphasis
on should but now just take a look at
the wounds on Jon's stomach and arms to
lose 40 of his blood John Wick would
need to bleed out about two liters and
thanks to the white shirts we can see
how much blood he's actually losing and
it's not enough this is merely a pint or
two of blood it's not enough to cause
him to die like this this also checks
out with the statistics according to an
annals of surgery study 88.3 percent of
people who get shot in the abdomen area
survive lastly we've seen him survive
this exact set of injuries before in
Chapter 2 John is shot twice in the
right side of his abdomen while fending
off one of the Assassins though it
clearly hurts Jon and causes him to hold
his wound and stumble about he does
survive it just fine so in John Wick's
final death scene he actually survives
but what about throughout the rest of
the movie could his injuries have just
added up what about getting hit by a car
John is hit by several cars throughout
these films which obviously can result
in a lethal injury 9.1 percent of
pedestrians hit by vehicles are killed
another 21.8 percent are severely
injured the big X Factor there is
ultimately how the hit occurs and how
fast the car is going in John wake
chapter 4 for instance we see him hit by
a car during his battle in the middle of
traffic notice though that this fight's
happening on a very specific Road the
Champs Lisa that circles around paris's
Arc to Triomphe a massive 12-lane
roundabout where the speed limit is 50
kilometers an hour or just over 30 miles
an hour on other streets in Paris where
we also see him get hit the speed limits
lower restricted to 30 kilometers or 18
miles per hour but here's the thing the
odds are in John's favor with all of
these cases only 33 percent of
pedestrians hit by Vehicles traveling 25
miles per hour are severely injured and
only 10 percent hit at 35 miles per hour
die these hits at those speeds while
they certainly look painful they're
likely some of the least dangerous
things that we see Wix survive
throughout the films so if cars aren't a
threat and bullets aren't a threat what
about Falls chapter 4 features an
incredible top-down fire fight looking
like it was ripped straight out of
Hotline Miami a firefight that ends with
him jumping out of a fourth story window
don't worry there's a conveniently
placed van that's going to break his
fall
four stories converts to roughly 43.3
feet or 13.2 meters and according to
various health and Medicine textbooks
just 50 of people who fall for stories
are actually able to survive so John
here is just flipping a coin with his
life but it's worth noting that that one
is actually one of his lower Falls
during a fight with a member of the high
table John falls from a balcony hits a
beam on the way down and then Falls flat
onto the concrete floor below this scene
was shot at a space called craftwork
Berlin and estimating from the
information that's available on their
website the total height of this fall
was roughly 50 feet or 15 meters what
are the odds of Jon surviving this
higher fall well believe it or not but
the beam actually helped his odds Keanu
Reeves is six foot one inch and we see
that he's falling about twice his body
height or 12 feet before he hits that
beam yes he's landing hard on his back
but it's enough to slow him down and
restart his fall at a lower level where
now he's only falling an additional 38
feet or 11 and a half meters according
to this scientific study the odds of
dying from a fall at that height is only
18 so it's likely that he's gonna
survive but shouldn't his back be broken
no actually Studies have shown that to
fracture a cervical spine you need a
force of about 3 000 Newtons that's
equal to the impact created by a 500
pound car crashing into a wall at 30
miles an hour so how close to this
number does John Wick get very you see
you can actually calculate Free Fall
energy as mass times gravity times
height of fall Keanu Reeves weighs in at
175 pounds and we know that he's falling
about 12 feet that gets us to
2847 joules of energy when he hits the
beam almost the 3000 Newtons to break
him but just not quite enough which
brings up an interesting point for as
painful as all those back-breaking Falls
look they seem to be there intentionally
the filmmakers are ensuring that they
never cross the four-story rule which
would then put Jon's odds of survival is
extremely unlikely and in moments when
he is falling from greater than four
stories like in here they try to make
sure to break his fall and is back with
a couple of painful stops on the way
down that puts Jon's scientific odds of
survival just on the right side of
believable while still looking
viscerally painful in the process but
just how far can they push these physics
case in point the mother of all falls
from John Wick 3 when he shot off the
top of the Continental true to form on
his way down he hits a slanted roof
bounces off a fire escape railing
crashes into another awning and then
smashes into the pavement the real world
location used as a stand-in for the
Continental Hotel here is one Wall
Street Court in New York City which
stands at a staggering 205 feet tall
more than three times taller than the
tumble that Jon takes off that nightclub
in chapter four and while that would
certainly be a fall that's impossible to
survive that's not actually what we're
seeing happen well yes one Wall Street
Court was visually what we see when Jon
actually falls he's falling from a much
smaller height if you count the floors
as Jon falls down he's actually tumbling
eight full stories and considering a
typical story in New York is 10 feet
tall that translates to a whopping 80
foot or 24 meter fall still His Highest
by a wide margin that said what damage
would we expect to be done here well not
as much as you might expect the slanted
Surface Two stories down would actually
help dissipate most of his initial
falling energy resetting him largely
back to zero the last part of the Fall
would also be survivable as the awning
catches him about 30 feet down the
biggest issue as you might expect is the
fire escape here John is falling a
little over two stories to land right on
his back on a thin metal rail that would
almost absolutely break his back again
plugging into our handy equation energy
equals mass times gravity times height
he's landing on that railing with nearly
4 750 joules of energy to put it another
way he's falling at a speed roughly
equivalent to 36 miles per hour and then
coming to a dead stop on that railing on
his back the fact that Jon is able to
walk away from the Continental fall at
all let alone continue his Rampage six
months later in chapter four yeah
nothing short of impossible but perhaps
John's most serious injury is the first
that he sustains in the entire franchise
towards the start of the very first
movie one of the goons takes an aluminum
bat to the back of Jon's head he's then
kicked in the gut in the face struck
across his left arm by the bat and then
punched in the face again rendering him
unconscious now the hits to the gut in
the arm could have easily left him with
internal abdominal injuries or broken
bones but those are far from the most
concerning thing to happen here the fact
that John's hit in the head multiple
times hard enough that he's knocked out
that would give him a Grade Three
concussion that is serious according to
the CDC that should have given Jon
slurred speech decreased coordination
confusion intense headaches nausea for
weeks if not months after this injury
now this is an important fact because we
see Jon get hit in the head multiple
times throughout the series even knocked
out again after getting hit with a car
but he shows no signs of any lingering
or life-threatening symptoms from all
these concussions he's still able to
carry on conversations immediately after
waking up
settle down oh you manage that anyways
anyways look
in short over the course of two weeks
from chapters one through three John
Wick is shot stabbed hit by cars
dangerously cauterizes a wound been
close enough to an explosion that he's
thrown by it and fall in a distance that
breaks his back all of these wounds are
far worse than what finally quote
unquote kills him at the end of chapter
four it can only lead me to conclude
that John Wick just isn't dead at the
end of the latest movie the name is dead
the legend of John Wick is dead but the
man no he's still alive and out there
but that still doesn't answer the
question of how not how he survived
chapter four I think we've covered that
fairly well but how he survived chapters
one through three that is a brutal two
weeks that should have killed him
multiple times over but you know what I
think I have an answer loyal theorist
see in a short that we released a few
weeks ago we proved that the blind
assassin Kane has to have himself
superpowers it is the only way that he'd
be able to feel what cards he's dealt
during the chapter 4 poker game and I
don't think that he's the only super
powered assassin that we're seeing in
these movies Jon has powers too
specifically a healing Factor akin to
Wolverine or Deadpool now that might
seem like a bit of a leap but we see
evidence of Jon's healing factor in
action during the films in chapter one
John gets this cut on his nose and yet
it's completely gone when chapter two
begins this is supposed to be happening
immediately afterwards and even a
superficial cut like this could take a
few days to heal completely want a more
serious wound that gets magically healed
remember John getting shot in his
abdomen twice during chapter Two And yet
when a stab wound on his shoulders being
treated in chapter three we see that
those gunshots on his abdomen have
completely healed over no scars no wound
dressing no stitches no nothing chapter
3 takes place immediately after chapter
two and the filmmakers cared enough
about continuity that Jon is wearing the
same shirt with the same blood stains
from those gunshot wounds and yet no
actual evidence of those wounds on his
body exist all because John Wick has a
super healing Factor that's why he's
able to keep going and going and going
throughout these films getting up every
time he's knocked down killing every
assassin that gets sent his way John
Wick isn't dead because he is literally
Immortal thematically it works real well
Jon and Kane agree before their Final
Duel those cling to death
live for those who are cling to life die
and no one clings to death more than
John Wick it's also worth noting that
the John Wick franchise was born during
an era where superhero films dominated
the box office I suspect that this one
might just be a sleeper superhero film
grittier more realistic but still
starting someone with Larger than Life
special abilities and now what do we see
as I record this they're already
announcing a John Wick chapter 5. so
when it's revealed that John Wick has
faked his death because he's a man who
literally can't die remember where you
heard it first but hey all this work
taken down the Assassin sent by the high
table couldn't be easy on an empty
stomach thankfully for Mr John Wick it's
easier than ever to make sure you get
good food with our sponsor for today's
episode factor factor is a meal service
that's focused on getting fresh never
frozen meals delivered directly to your
front door that means if you're too busy
to meal plan but you want to still make
sure you're eating well factor is gonna
be your secret weapon I think you guys
know at this point that I'm just
incredibly busy between trying to bounce
all these channels and having a family
so having these sorts of meals just show
up so I don't have to go to the grocery
store it has been awesome I also don't
have to worry about shopping or cutting
anything Factor's meals are just popped
into the microwave and they're ready in
two minutes without any hassle of prep
or cleanup I love that efficiency and
the meals are delicious Factor is now
also owned by hella fresh so you have
yourself an even wider variety of meals
that you can choose from they have food
for keto calorie smart vegan and veggie
and Protein Plus Lifestyles all prepared
by chefs and approved by dietitians
basically if you have yourself a
specific diet there is likely a factor
meal that's going to fit your needs
everyone in the office also loves these
meals like when they come shipped to us
we all compete for who gets them on any
given Lunch Period a production manager
Justin actually really loves the herb
crusted chicken though it kind of makes
me wonder what John Wick's preferred
meal would be strikes me as a pork chop
guy anyway if you want to skip the
hassle of cooking but you still want to
eat some delicious food that's ready in
a matter of minutes head to factor75.com
f-a-c-t-o-r-75.com or just click the
link below and use the code film
theory50 to get 50 off your first Factor
box again that is 50 off your first
Factor Box by heading over to
f-a-c-t-o-r-75.com and then using the
promo code f i l m t h e o r y 50 or you
know you can just click the link in the
description if you don't want to worry
about typing all that out thank you
again to factor for sponsoring today's
episode and for supplying me the last
couple of months of my healthy meals and
as always remember my friends it's all
just a theory a film Theory and cuts
[Music]
foreign